hello and welcome to this video playing
visualize visual eyes okay and i'm home
for animals oh if he allows me but i'm
not coming for bo go on to try something
sharper if he goes Knight f3 instead
he's reinventing theory coming up with
no okay still just still just the names
oh um okay f3 I go see 5 them it's line
is super sharp and I keep forgetting how
it works absolutely on this video I
don't remember my own book then this is
round that's real okay i'm playing
quickly because it looks fairly logical
to to do okay yeah interesting here
couple of good options a bishop a six
green 85 I think we Nate 5m but a three
is more or less some loss of a temple as
blackville have to take them in many
cases anyway so I came would you like to
prevent them from castling what's
probably not happening ok I can also
take on d5 that's also very very logical
but I'd like to if possible get the
Queen to see phone I Bishop g5 though I
didn't play that well can just about
play this have I have six from with the
Queen there from a six
and well it's really bad opening result
after that bad a three move by white
I want to and I want to keep make it
difficult for him to cancel queena 896
he gives queen against two looks but I
think this should be a decent position
for the Queen with 95 coming and so on
I will play knight c6 next and give him
one of the pawns but I wanted to make
sure that you cannot easily Castle King
f2 is always running into night c65 d3
this kind of thing stir I was really bad
opening player maybe I should have just
taken on d5 and was the simplest looking
thing can almost pre-move knight c6 here
if I will almost play that no matter
what
no he does gasps oh yeah why not why not
interesting yeah strong move 96 he will
move the night presso d2f form I take it
to 20 x 96 there is no big point here I
have to have to do that and now my
structure is really really awful Kelso
tap cast lots was strong hmm ok I cannot
allow night f5
yeah pretty pretty awful it's the last
night at 50 but what can I do
yeah I don't I'm sure what is the point
can just play book okay well maybe this
is too but maybe this is this is good
but I was thinking just just move the
rock here okay um fatigue s look there
check I don't see the maid don't see the
mate so I'm taking it
and 97's the problem but okay I can
actually just give the Queen here right
I mean just 97 that's the thing and then
queen have six this is actually really
made probably I'm still losing but
somehow I felt like it should have been
something easier Queen f6 is the thing
and I cannot check him I'd f6 it's
always a chick who's always a check time
warning
all my pieces are uncovered check
unprotected I mean check check check and
it's almost impossible not to lose stuff
in this kind of situation
check
check check check check it's probably
some kind of mate it can also just a guy
seven this is a big issue check check oh
my god and I'd be six is winning they
don't so check night takes if three is
the only the thing oh you prevented that
check check check it's not mate is not
made I thought into made haha i thought
it's made check ok take it game wrong
anyway yeah and i said i'm going to stop
to complain if people play on time but i
don't see myself resigning any of this
stuff either I really don't give a damn
ok so that was pretty awful so how can i
I mean ok maybe I should have just done
the normal thing is that the weirdest
thing ever i'm watching your videos as
we speak I am crazy game now yeah he
night XD fire this is the the standard
tactic here which I saw but I thought we
near five was better ok yes to check
here and this is the trick check and
this is this the 96 this is what i
should do it is better I guess yeah iam
the thing was that was all nice and good
but Bishop g5 is strong yeah he was very
well played that was just clearly worse
and here it starts to okay the engine
actually thinks it doesn't work chad is
and now taking I of course and this is
not really precise ok chat so the engine
I wants to do this but here I'm not
worse rather the opposite hmm ok and
here I'm losing right him I mean this is
a lost position yeah I'm losing and I
pretty much was losing why for quite a
while I would actually think i have made
that supported dev ok i was crazy but I
think yeah I think I don't know maybe
that was a fair result no ok thanks for
watching